[Applaudissements]
bien chers amis mes chers amis je
voudrais tout d'abord vous dire le
plaisir que j'ai d'être à côté de
valérie pécresse
c'est ma voisine aller présidente d'une
petite région suffisant d'une grande
région et j'ai la chance mon cher
christian grâce au paysan normand et à
la puissance de l'industrie
agroalimentaire normande de pouvoir
normes de pouvoir nourrir les
franciliens régulièrement et donc mach
hervé ma chère vallée riche et très
heureux d'être à tes côtés ce soir pour
ce meeting c'est important chers amis je
voudrais vous dire que je n'ai jamais
hésité un seul instant quand laurent m'a
posé cette question simple que feras tu
pour la campagne des élections
européennes
notre discussion a duré cinq minutes
et après on a parlé de la vie on a parlé
de la vie et notre discussion a duré
cinq minutes pour une raison très simple
mes chers amis c'est qu' il n'y a aucune
raison que le centre et la droite ne
soit pas ensemble à chaque élection
mes chers amis bon une seule raison
ou tout du moins pour deux raisons la
première raison c'est que nous sommes
ensemble à tous les échelons des
collectivités
nous sommes ensemble dans les régions
nous sommes ensemble dans les
départements et nous sommes ensemble
dans les communes elite été disons le au
moins schizophrène de considérer que
pour cette élection européenne
nous aurions pu faire un autre choix et
puis nous sommes ensemble mesdames et
messieurs parce que quand on est au
centre ou au centre droit on est avec la
droite parce que nous défendons des
valeurs communes qui s'appelle par
exemple le principe de responsabilité le
principe d'une organisation
décentralisée du pays et parce que nous
sommes pour la lutte contre les déficits
et pour la bonne gestion publique et
comme moi sur la plupart de nos valeurs
rien ne nous sépare et donc nous devons
être ensemble aujourd'hui comme mesdames
et messieurs nous devons être ensemble
demain et mesdames et messieurs nous
devons être ensemble demain parce que
derrière cette élection européenne se
dresse un enjeu absolument capital pour
le pays et c'est en jeu il s'appelle
construire une alternative une
alternance pour qu'en 2022 nous soyons
en mesure de proposer autre chose que
l'échec des manuels macron ou la folie
de marine le pen
et mesdames et messieurs pour cela il ya
une seule solution - qui j'aime le dire
ici - qui n'est jamais tremblé ni fléchi
mon cher bono au moment des élections
présidentielles de 2017
nous devons être tous rassemblés c'est
parce que nous serons retrouver la voie
de l'unité la voie de l'unité au sein
des républicains disons que c'est déjà
fait et la voie de l'unité au sein de
l'opposition
et c'est cette double condition qui nous
permettra de pouvoir engager
progressivement le chemin qui dira aux
français il ya autre chose que de
vouloir vous enfermer dans un débat
infini qui serait moi ou le chaos mois
où marine le pen comme le dit emmanuel
macron chaque jour et bien à ce titre là
je suis très heureux que philippe vigier
le président de territoire et liberté
soit avec nous ce soir comme loïc hervé
sénateur de la haute savoie et comme
sylvie goy chavent qui est sénatrice de
l'ain et qui est là encore un petit peu
de chemin à faire parce qu'elle est
encore udi il faut que tu dises sylvie à
tous les u10 qu'il n'ya plus qu'une
seule chose à faire c'est de voter utile
de venir avec nous plutôt que de rester
dans une liste qui fait de bon sens
chers amis dites-leur tous et je suis
sûr que valérie sera trouvé les moyens
de le dire à jean christophe lagarde qui
l'y a probablement un meilleur moyen
pour gagner les prochaines élections que
de rester diviser et de témoigner dans
des scores qui s'approche du zéro pointé
la deuxième chose que je voudrais vous
dire mes chers amis concerne là ça sera
plus facile pour toi lors de la
prochaine réunion de la majorité
régionale valérie la deuxième chose que
je voudrais vous dire mes chers amis
c'est que emmanuel macron nous vend un
projet européen qui est un projet
partagé par personne en europe et donc
il écrit une fable une fable qu'il est
incapable comme l'a très bien montré
joseph où gérard de partager avec
d'autres européens et la première
d'entre elles c'est à dire la
chancelière allemande
mesdames et messieurs on est tout de
même probablement pour la première fois
depuis 1958 dans un schéma complètement
inédit la construction européenne a
reposé sur le couple franco allemand et
sur chaque période de l'histoire de
france
on peut écrire et y mettre des noms
c'est de gaulle à de noël c'est schmid
giscard c'est schröder chirac c'est kohl
mitterrand c'est sarkozy merkel et bien
mesdames et messieurs pour la première
fois on a une premier ministre
chancelière allemande qui vous explique
jamais un n'a été autant dans la
confrontation avec le président de la
république française
emmanuel macron vous raconte que le
projet européen qu'il défend il serait
capable de l'imposer et de le porter au
sein des 27 pays de l'union européenne
vous voyez bien que par cette seule
expression de ce soir on voit
un des projets qui au sein d'an marche
ne repose sur aucun fondement sérieux et
je voudrais simplement citer un seul
exemple devant michèle alliot-marie et
edouard balladur
c'est la question de la défense
européenne mesdames et messieurs
emmanuel macron nous avons dû dans un
premier temps l'armée européenne
alors ça fait plaisir aux français
mesdames et messieurs l'armée européenne
mais en réalité l'armée européenne ne
repose sur rien parce qu'il n'y a aucun
pays européen qui ne souhaitent
construire cette armée européenne
et deuxièmement mesdames et messieurs on
est malheureusement dans un schéma que
nous français ne pouvons que regretter
c'est que tous les pays européens ou
presque ont démissionné en matière de
défense et de sécurité en laissant les
américains assurer leur sécurité à
travers le bouclier atlantique
et donc quand emmanuel macron vont une
idée probablement populaire et partagé
par nombre de nos compatriotes d'une
armée européenne
on constate que dans les faits cette
armée européenne n'a aucune chance de
pouvoir se mettre en place
pourquoi parce qu'il existe déjà des
instruments et arnaud danjean on sait
très bien et que ces instruments là qui
s'appelle les bateaux groupe
les gt 15 cents et bien c'est battle
group mesdames et messieurs qui existe
depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années qui
fait que 15 cents hommes sont
constamment formés pour pouvoir
intervenir comme une force de réaction
rapide donc jamais été mise en oeuvre en
europe parce qu aucun pays européen n'a
considéré qu'un jour les conditions
étaient réunies
même quand s'il s'agissait du mali et
que lorsqu'on parle du corps européen ou
de l'état-major de leur corps il y à 800
hommes qui ne sont intervenus que dans
un seul ou dans un seul schéma ou
une seule configuration qui a été celle
d'être avec l'alliance atlantique en
afghanistan
et quand emmanuel macron évoque l' armée
européenne mesdames et messieurs j'ai
simplement envie de lui poser cette
question m'est cher président qui serait
le patron de cette armée européenne qui
décideraient de l'engagement des forces
des conditions de l'engagement du feu du
langue de l'engagement de tel ou tel
corps dans telles ou telles conditions
faudrait-il réunir la commission
européenne les 27 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement pendant plusieurs jours
pour déterminer ces conditions et
j'ajoute mesdames et messieurs pour
l'européen convaincu que je suis
s'il ya bien un sujet sur lequel je
souhaite que nous restions dans un
schéma qui est celui d'une souveraineté
et d'une indépendance totale c'est bien
la question de ma défense et de la
sécurité
je n'ai aucune envie de confier ma
défense ma sécurité
emma souveraineté aux bataves aux
allemands aux italiens et à qui que ce
soit car pour moi il s'agit de l'essence
même d'une nation
alors ça c'est l'histoire de d'emmanuel
mâcon c'est la marmotte qui met le
chocolat dans le papier si vous
connaissez cette histoire et puis de
l'autre il ya marine le pen et qui vous
expliquent que si tout va mal c'est à
cause de l'europe
et bien non mesdames et messieurs aussi
la france et un taux de chômage beaucoup
plus élevé que la plupart des pays
européens ce n'est pas la faute de
l'europe si mesdames et messieurs nous
avons un système judiciaire qui est
classée 25e au sein du conseil de
l'europe ça n'est pas la faute de
l'europe
si nous avons 150 mille jeunes qui
sortent du système éducatif chaque année
ça n'est pas la faute de l'europe
et si mesdames et messieurs ma chère
valérie mon cher renault nous avons un
système de formation si compliqué qui
nous empêchent d'être efficace pour la
formation des demandeurs d'emploi ça
n'est pas la faute de l'europe
et si nous jetons l'argent à travers les
fenêtres au point d'arriver à être le
pays avec le déficit de l'état le plus
élevé de tous les pays européens et avec
le niveau de prélèvements obligatoires
le plus élevé de tout le cpe
ça n'est pas non plus la faute de
l'europe c'est parce que nous n'avons
pas su créer les conditions du
redressement
alors chers amis nous avons désormais
une petite dizaine de jours pour eux
nous mettre en situation d'être une des
très belles surprises de cette élection
européens et nous pourrons l'être parce
que je vous le dis comme d'autres je ne
connaissais pas françoise aviez bellamy
qui n'avait pas eu la même élégance que
pour valérie pécresse de venir me
soutenir pendant l'élection régionale
je n'avais pas lu ses ouvrages de
philosophie jean confesse mais je les ai
écoutés et maintenant je vais vous dire
une chose simple
je suis presque au point de me dire
qu'une étoile est née dans le ciel de la
politique française
tu dois
hier j'avais un certain nombre de rendez
vous avec des membres du gouvernement
pour défendre l'idée d'une
décentralisation et d'une meilleure
efficacité de l'action publique est un
des ministres me dis mais comment tu
peux défendre ce mec de droite
je lui dis mais est-ce que tu l'as déjà
écouté une fois au moins
elle m'a promis que ce soir lt coûterait
et bien moi je les ai écoutés mesdames
et messieurs
eh bien je vais vous dire une chose
j'aime quelqu'un qui fait appel à
l'intelligence qui a la culture qui a la
gentillesse qui a la modestie encore et
qui dit aux français un message simple
oui nous sommes européens
mais oui nous voulons une autre europe
une europe qui très clairement affiché
un enjeu de civilisation parce que nous
avons créé en europe le plus beau
système qui associe liberté égalité
liberté et sécurité et qui a fait de la
proue du respect de l'homme et de son
mythe de son humanité
un enjeu fondamental oui c'est un enjeu
d'efficacité parce que nous avons besoin
d'un système qui marche moins
technocratique et répondant aux enjeux
qui sont les nôtres et enfin on a besoin
d'une europe qui souhaite une europe
puissance parce que nous sommes à un
moment où le monde très clairement est
en train de basculer
et bien quand on dit ça on a le droit
d'être européen
mais on a aussi le droit de dire et de
dire aux français on veut autre chose
qu'une fable emmanuel macron ou qu'un
procès sans fondement marine le pen et
nous avons là avec françoise aviez
bellamy le plus beau et le plus grand
des candidats pour réussir ce formidable
exploit
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]